allez on va accueillir chérix isère pour
les ouvriers
[Applaudissements]
ça va très bien on savait très contente
de voir un simple caillou des césars ce
week end et bats-toi c'est les lauriers
c'est dès lors il s'est un petit peu
différent lorsque je veux remettre les
lauriers à tout ce que j'ai vu à la télé
ce week-end dont je ne remettrai rien à
tpm des people que comme d'habitude j'ai
pas regardé évidence a animé par notre
radio mathieu qui revient très bien
marché leader tnt c'est vrai très faire
c'est maintenant inquiète je vais un
petit peu parlé des césar qui
malheureusement n'ont pas fonctionné
vendredi soir ça va
cyril on sait que la division française
n'a aucun secret pour vous oui aucun
cette réponse vous pouvez même donné des
audiences démission trois mois avant la
diffusion
ça c'est très fort vous tempérament il
se trompe vous trompez jamais jamais
jamais d'accord est-ce que vous rappelez
du 8 novembre dernier
non non pas du tout à écouter on veut
apprendre que kad merad allait animer la
cérémonie est tout de suite vous avez
donné votre pronostic d'audience n'ont
toujours rien alors oubliez donc de vous
remettre le laurier du plus grand
animateur télé qui est aussi le plus
grand visionnaire des audiences casey
ratt pour les césars qui va devra se
régaler moi je suis comment au rendez
vous le lendemain ben vous verrez moi je
pense qu'il va faire un carton
d'audience eh ouais je vous dis que ce
sera le meilleur score de ces cinq
dernières années vous verrez
m
[Musique]
l'erreur est humaine à perdre en replay
gens rient plus je sais que tu sais qu
il paraît que ça car tu n'es tu vas voir
tu vas apprendre dans la gueule avait
pas mis de billets vraiment vous y
mettrez un billet jeu parce que comme
j'ai pas entonner vos excuses comme des
couacs comme dans là on voit dans
l'extrait que je dis attendez le
lendemain j'ai pas entendu vos excuses
alors oui comme j'ai eu raison
oui alors qu'il n'y aura pas d' excuses
n'ont en revanche demain oui si on vous
sonne sonne à votre porte et que sans
recommander ou vrai oui je suis à vous
et merci merci alors si elle veut être
un visionnaire et d'ailleurs vous
pourriez largement ouvrir votre cabinet
de voyance regarder ça serait ça serait
cool j'aimerais bien alors vendredi soir
j'ai donc regardé les césar et pour ceux
qui ne connaîtraient pas le principe de
césar c'est une cérémonie où des
spécialistes de cinéma récompensent des
films que personne n'a vu ouais alors
c'est comme si en foot on donnait le
ballon d'or à agent steven port d'alon
joue en 3e division suisse il est très
bon mais personne ne connaît par exemple
alors guillaume canet revenus venu
remettre le césar du meilleur
réalisateur
et parmi les nommés ya vingt ans et
meilleur ami gilles lellouche manque de
bol quand il ouvre une enveloppe c'est
pas son pote qui viennent le trophée et
même si liam cadette un bon comédien des
fois il arrive pas à masquer sa
déception
il remporte le laurier du mec qui
n'arrive pas à cacher qu'il aurait
préféré que ce soit son poste qui
viennent le césar alors en général quand
quelqu'un annonce un vainqueur aux
césars il le fait dans la joie le
sourire de césar du meilleur espoir
masculin est attribué à dylan revers les
petites mains
et voilà maintenant l'annnonce de
guillaume canet le césar de la meilleure
réalisation est attribué à jacques
audiard pour les franciscains jouer
derrière moi je suis très heureux qu
alex lutz ont remporté le césar du
meilleur acteur et il est il
exceptionnel très bon alors on est tous
là de laurent weil le monsieur cinéma de
canal+ il connaît toutes les plus
grandes stars du cinéma mondial brad
pitt george clooney lorànt deutsch
mais malheureusement ils connaissaient
pas encore robert redford la soirée
laurent weil a attendu sa rencontre avec
robert faure de rouge bien sûr
la tente était très longue son interview
beaucoup moins je remets à laurent weil
le laurier de journalistes qui est venu
aux césars juste pour voir robert
redford
en attendant robert redford de césar
d'honneur cette année ici didier tu le
vois voilà le on attend en attend robert
de journée le monsieur est légèrement en
retard il très souvent voilà et
malheureusement on l'attend alors en
attendant robert redford je sais pas si
sandrine pouvoir rester encore un petit
peu avec moi
le grand moment arrive laurent weil va
enfin pouvoir faire une longue interview
de robert redford john collée sur le
coût de ce projet pour vous qu'est ce
que ça représente et césar et recevoir
ce césar d'honneur écoutez moi je suis
ravi d'être ici parce que j'adore la
france et j'adore paris
[Rires]
quelqu'un de généreux
voilà janeiro s'assoit pas sur les
fiches de paye nous est généreux mais
quand c'est gratuit vous avez encore
plus généreux par exemple vous prêtez
souvent là là là sur facture la régie de
touche pas à mon poste et à notre
émission que ça vous prêter à des
émissions qui ont envie d'avoir des
problèmes techniques
si vous les danses l'amour voilà
forcément pendant le discours très
émouvant de robert redford qui recevait
son césar d'honneur il ya eu un gros
souci de son vous allez voir que tout le
monde s'en fout de ce qui arrive à notre
pauvre bomb redford et voici le laurier
de la cérémonie qui n'aurait pas dû être
géré par la régie de tpm p
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous avez une aventure romain
son nom avant vincent avec avec jarry
est peut-être al hilal nador dalens plus
moi j'adore tallec émission print où
l'audience était très dure face c'est
vrai qu'on en oublie d'en parler
d'ailleurs c'était vendredi on l'a
oublié les missions à l aventure en août
ont salué jarry parce qu'ils n'en trouve
être étant nommé lieux l'ont juste salué
comme ça là là là à mon avis c'est
l'émission combat laventure robinson
vous avez la revoir 2010 passera au
sénat mais cher et en plus j'aime bien
ce groupe j'aime bien cette émission
mais l' aventure robinson alors avec
jari on aime beaucoup en pl toi oui ok
mais c'est vrai que quand il est quand
il est dans en plein milieu du pacifique
c'est un peu plus compliqué il a peur de
tout ce qui entoure
il a peur de tout ce qui nous entoure
par exemple il a même peur de son talkie
walkie alors je donne à jarry le long
rifle du nez qui part sur une île
déserte alors qu'il hurle quand on
éteint la lumière des réponses
vous allez je te dis
[Musique]
moi qui voulais pas salir mon pantalon
[Applaudissements]
allez faites l'un des traits à ce qu'on
peut montrer dont celui je voulais
montrer c'est ce que le mec a peur de
tout j'arrive s'essuie le magnéto juste
avant ce qui a peur de tout donc le
laurier du mec qui part sur une île
déserte alors qu'il hurle quand la
lumière étaient mes idées mes idées
j'espère qu'avec talent on va tout péter
mal aux pieds
ça c'est fait le plein
à tous